em cima da moto com placa de pare e
agora vou fazer o projeto boa jogar todo
mundo agora é com ele no sushi chego lá
o quê fechado no oxi chegou a tal que tá
fechado é isso que acontece em seus
perfis fechar as portas para os artistas
agora o índice vai botar gasolina na
moto porque ele tem 22 da pequena
daquelas que têm impacto e salgado já tá
tá tá tá tá tá tá
é foi a maior delas é muito quieto pois
é agora a gente chegou aqui no sushi
eyetech medo de na minha vitória
garantiu a quem substituiu xuxa estamos
aqui no sushi já xuxa após brigar com
vocês o que é o verdão venda blog
everyday pio vamos jogar todos os dias
de abril do dia 11 até o dia 30 de junho
que nã o hã
quem teve o enrolado em faro vai servir
para poder acelerar a apanhou de vídeo
vai ter de novo todo dia até o dia 30 ou
31 de abril não sei quanto dinheiro é
tempo que então se você quer que teve e
todo dia eu sei que já não gostei que eu
quero ver se a galera vai curtir mesmo
esse negócio de videogames a wimdu perde
perde todo dia ele vai ficar sem graça
meu filho a inteligência é um pouco de
ansiedade de jesus abençoa as pessoas
com a atividade intensa de fazer de tudo
e eu vou te deixar de reflexão é melhor
desejo da van do q2 madruga na mão
o time da vila belmiro é assim né
agora ele quer jogar com um talento de
gente assim que meus vantagem não sei
como é que faz parte do cartaz pessoa
não está com medo ainda vence precisamos
mostrar pra vocês
angya vasco miguel que agora vou ter que
passar
meu deus quem fez 31 nunca nada jurídico
a itu e assim é muito bom conhecer sobre
o desaparecimento substituição já vi
todas as fãs são quatro rapazes um de
segurança trabalhavam na obra no
shopping mas o índice não pode filmar no
shopping que é crime amigas obriga o
filme no shopping ea mãe dela senão isso
não pode mais tomar refrigerante não vou
lá e tomou dois gols a equipe tanto do
wii o que está fazendo as 10 horas da
noite mãe e até comendo leite lindote
sou radical do islã radical de imagens a
vida do outro
eu comecei a ficar com a água do que
pede 18 pegar falando na vida local a
qual na sua vida porque tudo que ouviu
combinação de madrugada não foi dani eu
como meio nesta ontem na praia no meu só
da minha boca está conectado e tirando
assim bananas de pijamas de sendo a do
estadual pois é a galera já que não
tenho muita coisa interessante pra fazer
vou fazer uma propaganda de parte de
versões para você está
esse parque
nós temos as melhores condições de
imagens melhores condições de brinquedos
nem comigo a melhor segurança para o seu
filho
aqui nós temos a melhor segurança para
seu filho vem com a gente
hoje a galera agora estou bem aqui e
receber abusa nova essa música é legal
do rio tem uma destas não vai decidir
quando vai tomar tantas link da
inscrição do piaí o primeiríssimo
implicando que botar um favor uma
sapatada o que eu faço e quero aqui na
liga na descrição do vídeo é o site da
campanha é o primeiro com gás quanto eu
pudesse é bom uso dessa que lá pode
comprar e muito obrigado sem deixar
barricada de é um engano acesso à
energia de itaipu parou de vaga aqui tem
que passar devagar
oi tudo bem vou explicar para vocês e
como vai ser um velho que eu vou fazer
pra vocês só que eu não sei o que
acontece com as pessoas no final toda
vez que eu faço diferença você faz tudo
mas eu gostava do jeito de antes minha
gente não vou mudar nada um ontem quando
vai ter é um mês um vídeo todo dia só
isso mas o índice diante do estado
diante mas sei qual hoje é terça tem o
primeiro venda hoje amanhã quarta dia de
vídeo novo como sempre vai ter um vídeo
igual como era sempre entendeu sócia na
quinta vai te vi na sexta vai ter de ir
num salão vai ter filho como era e no
domingo vai ter na segunda vai ter fim
na terça vai ter vídeo na quarta o mesmo
gente vai seguir tudo como é
ou seja todo dia vou fazer vídeo mas na
quarta e no sábado que é filho normal
então vida normal como era no seu hotel
que a agenda dessas pessoas a vontade de
pegar uma pedra do edifício
obrigado você está assistindo esse vídeo
obrigado muito obrigado 10min como um
vídeo advogando todo o dia e voltam a
cor do meu dia eu quero saber o que é
que você faz todo dia me disse que você
mas todo dia comenta aqui embaixo disse
a psp 43 da equipe na indy lights o time
vai ter
olhe no phantom ii
então clique no link e amanhã esse mesmo
horário tem vídeo no vimeo
é a primeira vez que estava aqui no meu
canal clicando de repente toda a gente
bebe nos vai saber falou ana joão santos
e fez uma oração um filho